hey guys dr. Berg here in this short
video we're going to talk about the
three factors that affect oxygen and
their nutritional factors okay in the
body so what happens is we have this
condition called acidosis that's
different than alkalosis it means your
body's too acid so the ph is too low and
we're talking about in the blood
normally the blood pH should be slightly
alkaline and what happens is the pH goes
slightly too low okay so we're just
talking to small little variations so
when your body is too acid your
breathing is going to be off you're
going to be like you're going to sigh
frequently you're going to kind of go
just can't get enough air it's air
hunger that's one of the big symptoms
all right so what do you do basically
very simple you take calcium magnesium
take it before bed take a little calcium
magnesium boom correct the pH the way
you get this condition is actually being
in ketosis for a period of time now it's
not a bad thing to be in ketosis because
you're burning fat but ketones are
acidic so you always have to offset it
by eating more calcium magnesium what I
do I consume so much vegetable that I
don't have a problem with a loss of
calcium okay or I might do some cheese
on a regular basis at night but just
realize if you're breathing soft you
need to alkalize your body with alkaline
minerals vegetables or calcium I'm using
would be the best thing all right
another way to know that you need
calcium is or magnesium is if you have
cramps and your cats okay so that's
acidosis secondly vitamin C deficiencies
vitamin C is stored in your adrenal
glands and vitamin C allows your body to
hold oxygen in the body longer and
better and so with the vitamin C
deficiency you won't be able to hold
your breath very long okay you will not
be able to you're going to get out of
breath when you climb stairs fast your
muscles will fatigue faster without
vitamin C especially if you're going up
in kind like your legs are heavier but
mainly you can't hold your breath for a
long
time that's adrenal problem but see the
adrenal stores vitamin C so you just
don't have enough vitamin C to store it
so it drops out and you have oxygen
problems mainly shows up incline walking
up stairs out of breath you know that
type of thing all right just make sure
that when you take vitamin C you always
take it from a food concentrate don't
take it from some synthetic pill because
the type of vitamin C you're getting
from synthetics are just ascorbic acid
and that's just one little piece of the
vitamin C complex you need the whole
vitamin C complex so I like to get it
from food base a good source would be
the wheatgrass juice powder that
actually provides the full vitamin C
complex then we get to vitamin E vitamin
E deficiencies will create problems with
high altitude breathing problems at the
top of every mountain top you will see
empty bottles of vitamin E because
mountain climbers consume a lot of
vitamin E to help them climb higher and
be able to survive at higher altitude so
if you're deficient in vitamin E the
muscle tissue in your heart will demand
so much more oxygen you'll start getting
cramping of the muscles in the heart and
so like angina pain chest pain is really
a vitamin E deficiency so vitamin E
provides the oxygen to the muscle tissue
if you're if you have muscle damage from
an injury you need vitamin E so vitamin
E is really important in recovering
muscle tissue and increasing oxygenation
of the muscle itself and the heart all
right where do you get vitamin E you get
it from raw nuts you get it from the
vegetables you get it from avocados okay
that's what you get you get it from a
lot of them you can get it from
basically seeds nuts vegetables things
like that alright so those are the three
factors that you want to look at if you
want to increase your oxygen carrying
capacity and I will see you in the next
video